we're going to talk about propositions
and logical operations in this little
clip and let's begin then with the
discussion of propositions so to a
mathematician and in particular in this
class we're going to use the word
proposition to refer to something that
is either true or false an example would
be there are five regular solids this
happens to be true and sometimes we even
some terms we even prove it it implies
for example that if you wanted to place
let's say a hundred fixed position
satellites around the earth in a uniform
way or you can't do it because there
isn't any
a hundred vertex regular solid the
biggest one is 20 vertices okay
well if I change it six guess what the
assertion there are six regular solids
is false so that's a simple-minded
example of a well-defined to
well-defined propositions one of which
is true one of which is false
propositions don't have to be true
always what are some non examples well
wake up is not a proposition because
it's an imperative it's not true or
false and where am I is a question it's
not true or false and it's 3:00 p.m. is
not a proposition because it's true or
false at any given moment but whether or
not it's true or false depends on the
time and that's a complication we don't
want to get into the idea is a
proposition is some fixed assertion that
say they're true forever or not true
forever now one of the reasons why
mathematicians bring up this abstraction
of propositions and the operations on
them that we're about to say is that
ordinary language tends to be ambiguous
and that of course will cause problems
in mathematical reasoning just as it
would in a program the most and one of
the most ambiguous of the phrases in
English that connects propositions is or
so let's look at this example
Greeks carry swords or javelins and if I
was transcribing this into precise math
notation I can say gee for Greeks
implies s for swords or J for javelins
so this is an assertion
if you're Greek then you carry a sword
or a Java Java line
Greeks implies sword or Jeff learn
really I should say Greek soldiers but
let that be implicit okay that's how
we're gonna translate this sentence into
just using these operators to paraphrase
what's going on the problem is what is
or mean and it turns out that for
javelins and swords it's true even if a
Greek carries both a sword in the
javelin this is an inclusive or a Greek
soldier would carry both a sword and a
javelin because in fact the Jeff wants a
good long distance weapon and a sword is
good for defending yourself close in and
you certainly want to have both
especially after you've thrown your
javelin and you don't have anything left
but the sword now this some many
standard notations for these logical
connectives that that build up larger
propositions out of component
propositions so one of the things is
this V symbol or disjunction symbol is
used by logicians often instead of or
and this arrow means implies or
sometimes a double bar arrow also means
employees but we're not going to get
into that I'm not gonna ask you to
memorize these symbols we'll just stick
to the words which don't take up that
much more room let's look at another
example
Greeks carry bronze or copper swords
syntactically this has the same
structure as the previous phrase but
we're going to translate it differently
and the reason is that we mean here that
a Greek soldier is not going to carry
both a bronze in a copper sword why is
that well bronze swords are just way
better than copper swords they'll slice
right through copper they're much harder
and it's not worth the weight to carry
this inferior copper sword when you have
a much better one so this time we mean
that Greeks carry exactly one of a
bronze or a copper so you'd carry a
copper so if you didn't have a access to
a bronze one and so now we translate
that into Greek implies B or bra B for
bronze or C for copper but this time we
use the X or X or means that one of them
is true exactly but not both and not
neither again there's this plus sign
notation
Forex or because as we'll see it acts a
little bit like adding numbers bond to
where one plus one is zero so let's be
more precise about the two definitions
of or an XOR and how they work and the
the assertion is that if I think of P
and Q as placeholders for propositions
that are either true or false
then the composite proposition P or Q is
true if and only if P is true or Q is
true or both are true and I could
express Express this assertion English
this is if and only if by giving you a
so-called truth table
where in these two columns are in these
all these rows I've enumerated all the
possible pairs of values of P and Q so P
and Q might both be true that one P
might be true and Q false P false Q true
and both of them are false and for each
of those possible combinations of the
truth values of P and Q I tell you the
truth value of P or Q and the notable
thing is this last row where I'm telling
you that the only way that P or Q is
false is if both P and Q are false okay
for X or as we said the P or X or Q is
true if and only if exactly one of P and
Q is true so if I was expressing that as
a truth table we see that where this TT
is false and where this FF is false
because it's not the case in either of
those two rows that exactly one is true
but the middle rows exactly one is true
and so px or Q is true so this truth
table is just a precise way of defining
how XOR acts on truth values there's
another connective and which works even
more straightforwardly the baloff value
of P and Q is true if and only if both P
and Q are true and there's is truth
table again the salient Row is that it's
true only if and only if both P and Q
are true another crucial logical
operation is the negation operation or
not a sum not P just flips the truth
value of P if P is true and true then
not P is false if not P is
truth and P is false and there's it's
very trivial truth table chubby because
there's only two values to be concerned
about when P is true not P is false when
P is false not P is true now one of the
places that this notion of combining
basic propositions into using logical
operations to build up more complicated
composite proposition is in programming
here's a typical kind of phrase that
comes from Java Java uses this double
vertical bar to mean or inclusive by the
way and double ampersand to mean
and so in Java this is a piece of
legitimate Java code that's doing a test
to evaluate this expression if X is
greater than 0 or X is less than or
equal to 0 and Y is greater than 100
then if that test comes out to be true
then you do a bunch of code that follows
the test upto some of the limiter that
tells you where to stop and if it's
false you just skip all that stuff and
go on so we use sort of boolean
expressions or logical expressions like
this in a very standard way in most
programming languages the other place
where these operations comes up in is in
digital logic and the digital circuit
designers have their own notation which
I'll just mention but we're not going to
again impose on you but you should be
aware of what a notation that u is that
we'll use as well because it's so
economical is that not X can be
abbreviated by writing a bar over the X
more generally not a complicated
expression can be abbreviated by writing
a bar over the complicated expression I
just saved some space and so we'll use
it but not the following in digital
logic on the idea is that you're talking
about circuits where the only
distinction of the signal that's coming
in electrically is whether it's a high
voltage or low voltage with high
voltages denoted by 1 and low voltage
denoted by 0 and the way the digital
logic behaves is the one corresponds to
true and the 0 corresponds to false then
the end operation is simply
multiplication because 1 or 0 times 1 or
0 is 1
when both of number one for ordinary
multiplication which is exactly the way
and behaves when one means true and zero
means false
unfortunately the digital designers use
plus when they mean or they do not mean
that one plus one is two they mean that
one plus one is one and just the thing
to watch out for part that's part of the
reason we're not going to use this
notation let's just stick to our
ordinary word notation that we give on
the right